et pour en parler on retrouve hassan
majed fondateur de dns consulting
cabinet d'analysé sur le moyen-orient
bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france pour en discuter
alors donald trump qui le dit clairement
il voulait éliminer bachar al assad
il avait démenti ces propos en 2018 ça
paraît tout de même assez hallucinant de
la part d'un président pourquoi être
revenu sur ses propos
à quelques mois de la présidentielle
disons que la réponse à cette question
réside dans la question elle-même on est
dans une période d'élections américaines
et danse dans cette époque dans cette
période assez incident racicot a c'est
essentiel importante
on va écouter regarder toutes sortes de
l'exagération d'exactions de la part des
deux candidats
si on a au début donc côté des pays du
golfe on a eu deux signatures comme vous
l'avez montré dont le repartage
précédent de deux pays du golfe qui ne
compte pas dans le conflit arabo
israélien
on a aussi quelque part des quelques
déclarations ou donald trump essaye de
se montrer dans une figure qui est plus
grande que la sienne et ses exagérations
là ne lui sont pas étrangères non ça ça
fait partie de son style de speech et
afin de montrer qu'il est qu'il y ait un
homme fort et puis qui renforce la
stature de son pays en tant que la
puissance dominante de la région
justement est-ce que ça peut jouer en sa
faveur est ce que sont ses conseillers
lui lui conseille finalement 2-2 de
faire ces déclarations à quelques mois
de la présidentielle
je pense qu'on assiste à du trempe isme
pur et dur parce que d'une part on
refait on revoit les discordes entre amp
et de nombreux conseillers qui ont dû
démissionner l'un après l'autre et la
critique est donc dans ce sens puisque
le général mattis qui était acquis et
est apprécié par l'ensemble des
personnes sur le terrain par l'ensemble
des soldats et l'ensemble des personnels
du ministre de la défense qu'il était en
quelque part et une serbie quelques mois
il était une icône sein du ministère de
la défense
on connaît bien la nuit graphique du
général mattis ça c'est une la deuxième
s'il pouvait faire ce genre de
ce genre d'action il me semble qu'il a
été qu'il a orchestré l'assassinât du
général qasem soleimani et la réponse de
son pays à savoir l'iran sur la base
américaine en irak a pu remettre les
compteurs à zéro
donc je ne pense pas que trump aurait pu
être capable de deux d'achille et une
autre guerre dans le cadre de son
programme
néanmoins en terme de ce mythe
symbolique autres à rien donc on assiste
à du tropisme curieux quel que soit donc
en fait les conseils donnés par ses
conseils alors dit mathis a déclaré que
trump était dangereux inapte et sans
boussole morale justement j'en reviens à
moyen-orient est ce que ces propos
pourraient avoir des conséquences sur le
moyen-orient notamment de la part de
l'iran allié de damas alors en termes de
propos je ne me pense je ne le pense pas
mais disons que il faut réfléchir en
fait au cas où transféré du est certain
que si train est réélu il y aura des
conséquences ou encore byden chaque aile
l'élection de l'un ou de l'autre aura
des répercussions sur l'ensemble du
processus au moyen-orient que ça soit
sur les dossiers syrie sur les dossiers
d'un certain nombre des pays du golfe et
aussi sur le conflit arabo-israélien
site rentrer ici on n'est pas loin
d'avoir une accélération de la violence
et peut-être des conflits même si ce
dernier clame que l'iran va pouvoir
signer un accord dans une semaine ou un
mois suivant sa réélection chose qui est
truquée du 36 maturi dur tandis que si
mathis et là on tourne en fait une
politique est classique a été adopté par
obama donc l'élection de l'un ou de
l'autre aura des répercussions majeures
sur l'ensemble de la région sur les
conflits et sur les dossiers qui sont en
suspens que ça soit en moyen-orient en
afrique du nord notamment indique
justement vous dites que c'est ça fait
partie du personnage ses propos un peu
chocs au moyen-orient comment est ce
qu'elle est perçue cette tentative
d'assassinât je parle pas seulement
venir en mai peut-être côté côté liban
ou des pays des pays avoisinants
jordanie est ce qu'il ya eu
des réactions me semble pas que les
réactions pourront sans majeur où on
sont d'une nature critique parce qu'ils
donneront en fait en sorte d'appui en
fait aux propos du président qui
connaissent très bien que le président
entrant est maître de son art du deal
tels que c'est écrit dans son bouquin à
part des critiques condamnant les propos
de 32 dans certains parties du
moyen-orient que ce soit au liban en
syrie ne va pas assister à des
rebondissements majeur parce que j'en
connais toutes les orientaux ont appris
à connaître ce personnel et ses
jaillissements qu'ils peuvent des fois
être non calculés et puis des fois
brusque était impulsif que comme le dit
gilles le général mattis assad majed
merci à d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes fondateur du
cabinet d'analystes sur le moyen-orient
dit anas consulting